say [ __ ] like that right it's a part of
any way we do otherwise
but if he's anemic okay
what we do this thing where we we have
an email question we answer it oh did
somebody send me a question we're doing
so go ahead on hopeful voice with Bobby
kalila and Eric Stonestreet second city
right there Chicago a little more moral
predicament and wanted to get a little
unhelpful advice I'm currently dating a
wonderful woman whom I'm like very much
recently she went on a vacation and
while she was gone something happened
that I'm not sure if I need to tell her
or not I ran into a woman I had hooked
up with years prior and we just had a
friendly chat and that seemed to be that
the next day she messaged me and started
to down the road to reminiscing about
our escapades I properly stopped her and
said I was seeing someone and that it
was was not appropriate for me to engage
into that type of conversation my
question is do I need to tell my
girlfriend or should I just forget about
it
I'm not to have a guy do the right thing
only to score points to my girlfriend so
is there any need for me to tell her
that he did nothing condense it tell me
what tell me what it is I feels guilty
that while his girlfriend was out of
town he was reminiscing with an ex about
their sexcapades via text or phone call
let's assume they met in person when
they were arraignment it's not on
purpose they met in person met in person
not on purpose but then continued
attacks after you okay and he was they
were talking about remember that one
time we did it classic yeah the giraffe
giraffe oh yeah it's hard to get up
there though I'll tell you that right
now you need a ladder or hot no I
wouldn't say anything I would not say
anything I mean first of all he's not
due unless he got a [ __ ] he feels
guilty so I don't know what thing he'll
put his he put the brakes on he put the
paint create clear boundaries he didn't
he stopped the conversation
he's like I'm seeing somebody we
shouldn't well Tom at that
another one hold on a second I want to
know what you would really do in real
life if you were to like reminisce with
an ex would you like tell me about it
like hey I caught up what what now we're
in dangerous Honduras yes so dangerous
listen if I okay if I first of all if I
went into let's say let's throw out one
sarah hyland we I'd used to date a girl
named Sarah Hyland that you're Sarah
Hyland yeah I know all right
she's a nice girl and she's married and
she's a lesbian right she's married to a
woman and I'm very I support it I'm
really into the lb lb so here's the deal
all right
yeah but I would say yeah and she was
like remember one time we did it in
Vegas yeah yeah that was weird what was
weird about it
well you I was you cared me like a
backpack River smells like a koala and
you're like a tree remember yeah you
always let me know when you catch up
with some of those and I do the same but
I had this most recent I've had
something similar happened to me where
an ex was trying to like push to
reminisce yeah and I felt the need to
always just put hahahaha because trying
to like deflect because I was
uncomfortable didn't want to say oh yeah
I remember that but instead of putting
like clear boundaries I just kept saying
haha and then never responded after yeah
if you if you if your mouth is around
another man's fleshy penis yeah you know
then and then that's gonna hurt me yeah
but don't you want a little warning
before it gets to that wow that's
interesting
a little warning hey I'm about to put my
mouth right but if the relationship is
already there it's over yeah right
that's if we're at a point where she's
about to have his mouth on her it's less
she's mouth on her time or either way
Rider Kashmir yeah but it the
relationship is over yeah you know but
what I do though even though I don't set
clear boundaries with him is I
the text with him like she does she
shows me dig pits yes yes guys send you
dick pics respectful it's not even it's
sending you that just strangers their
fans yeah
Rizzo doles out right I want to hear
something crazy I got I got a picture
through a friend okay
a friend of mine who is gay was
exchanging messages with another gay man
on a dating site and not knowing he's
friends with me
got a dick pic of a guy with Modern
Family on in the background and cam on
the screen with a big giant dick and the
guys hand around the stick and I'm in
the back mom mom I made it
you really do yeah well you're like
music on an elevator right you're just
like yeah
[Music]